he was copying from from so he had
access to like the Greek manuscripts or
something like that well first of all
that's not really possible for him to
have access to the Greek manuscripts and
for him to actually be studying
philosophy because if you look at his
life you'll realize that there's just
there's no way given given his
circumstances that he would have access
to that that's one thing the second
thing is if you actually look at the
books of Aristotle you look at you know
the things that they've written
Hippocrates on medicine and all of that
the amount of mistakes that they've
actually made in their descriptions are
numerous and you don't find these type
of mistakes in the Quran so that's one
thing second thing is they did not
describe in detail the way that the
firaon is describing in detail the
number of days and how that fetus
actually goes through several stages
none of these things have been described
in any form of detail so to make the
claim is actually it's very flimsy and
people try to try and bring a bunch of
names and all that they're like oh well
this person knew that and Aristotle knew
that and this guy knew that before but
they can't provide solid evidence
showing that this is exactly what it was
like so they just caught a bunch of
names they're like yeah they kind of had
an understanding of embryology they kind
of had a deeper understanding of science
well yeah maybe Aristotle was was more
knowledgeable and had a better
understanding of science than some of
the medieval European you know
philosophers or medical practitioners
during the you know the Catholic Church
times yeah that may have been the case
but it's not it's not the case that they
got all these theories are all these
things that are being talked about in
the Quran so there's a world of
difference people need to bring their
proof and that's why I lost the part
that says in the Quran how to burhanakum
in kuntum saw the plain and that's what
I like to use and bring your proof if
you're truthful and whenever you ask
them to bring their proof it's kind of
like a roundabout kind of ditching okay
let me give you another example and they
try to change the topic on you you know
and that's the thing you just gotta call
people out when they're making claims
they gotta bring their proof and it's
very important that they bring something
solid before we should even you know
listen to the rest of what they have to
say
you